(upbeat whistling music)
(TV static buzzes)
- What's like, the most
scorpion thing you've done?
- I lit my ex's clothes on fire.
- You didn't let him on fire
or them on fire so...
- No.
(group chuckles)
(electronic music)
- [Narrator] We brought
together are seven Scorpios.
- I'm a Scorpio.
- I am a Scorpio.
- [Narrator] One is a liar.
If the group discovers a liar is
they'll split a cash prize.
(intense electronic music)
If the liar survives,
they win the entire prize.
(cash register clings)
Who is the odd one out?
- So should you go
around and say birthdays?
- [Ileana] Starting with me?
- [Giselle] Yeah, sure.
- November 7th.
- November 14th.
- October 28th.
- We have the same birthday.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- [Ileana] Whenever Mindy
said that her birthday
was the same as mine.
I was kind of like,
that's interesting,
is it or are you just saying that.
- November 1st
- November 21st
- October 27th.
- Do people think like,
you're a mean person like,
cause of just your face?
- Yeah, I was gonna say like a stereotype.
You just automatically have RBF.
- [Chris] Yup.
(group agreeing)
I've been told like,
oh when I first met you,
I was super intimidated by you.
- [Group] Yes!
- Scorpio's are very like, sarcastic.
They're humor is dry, witty.
You look for people who are very shy,
reserved,
you know, into themselves.
Do you guys have any tattoos?
- Yeah, I have two.
I have this one
and Scorpio one so....
Oh, now, what is that of?
- [Erica] Oh, so it's a skeleton
with the scorpions tail
and then it says,
never trust the living cause Scorpios,
you know, they don't trust anybody.
So, you know.
- [Ileana] She says she's a Scorpio
and has a Scorpio tattoo,
so like, oh,
it could be like her
other Scorpio placements
that she really loves
and so she tattooed it
on herself or something.
- It's dedicated to Beetle Juice
cause never trust the living is also...
- That's like on of my favorite movies.
- [Erica] High five.
(alarm bell rings)
(electronic music)
- [Giselle] She was the
most shy of the group.
She was very reserved
and that kind of stuck out to me the most.
- [Mindy] He just kind of
seemed like he knew who he was
and was trying to show it immediately.
- [Erica] I figured if the
mole was gonna do something
they were gonna just
piggyback off of somebody's
birthday, so...
(music stops)
(alarm buzzing)
- [Mindy] When I said had
the same birthday as her,
I was like, I'm - I'm out.
I'm the first one out already,
I knew it.
- [Raina] Do y'all like believe
in astrology in general?
- Oh it's my job.
- Really?
- That's so cool.
- [Erica] I've been interested in it
ever since I was a little girl.
So it just kind of,
it was a path.
- So you could be very well
versed in all of the signs?
(record player scratches)
- No, because there are certain
signs that I do not like
and I do not study,
but you know a Gemini as
a Gemini for a reason.
Giselle pointed it out.
And I was like,
ah, I shouldn't have said that.
- I don't know anything
about any other sign
except for mine.
- If there's a post,
then I'll look for Scorpios.
- [Group] Yeah...
- Obviously that's the
only one that matters.
I'm gonna be honest,
I don't really believe in astrology.
So my main thing was just to be like,
confident about their birthday,
anything like that,
then that was a green flag for me.
- What's like the most
scorpion thing you've done?
- I lit my ex's clothes on fire.
- Okay. That's good.
- It's nothing.
- You didn't let him on fire so
or them on fire so...
- No
(group chuckles)
- I was just gonna say,
I guess the most Scorpio
thing I've done is like,
I've deleted all social media
and I kind of just went ghost for a while.
- Oh my God, I did that this year.
- [Ileana] Oh really?
- [Erica] Yeah.
- Do y'all have any
Scorpio characteristics
that you don't fit?
Like for me,
I know that Scorpios
are supposed to be like
really sexual
and stuff
and I'm actually asexual,
so something in the alignment
got messed up for me.
- Everything about Scorpio,
like that's just me.
- [Raina] That's so valid.
- [Giselle] I feel like when
you are talking about signs
not everybody embodies
all of the characteristics
but he was just like
hitting every single point,
so I was like,
Hmm. Okay.
Interesting, noted.
- I feel like I'm the same as him.
I feel like I just kind of,
I'm a theater student.
Well, I guess that, you know,
just being out in the open performing,
I'm still introverted, but...
- [Raina] But you like being
the center of attention?
- Singing, doing all that, yeah.
Well not attention just on stage.
- [Ileana] Right.
- I feel like it,
it just lets out the
energy that I have pent up.
(bell dings)
(electronic music)
- [Chris] When I was grabbing a paper,
I looked inside the box really quick
and I saw my name ran down,
so I knew obviously it was her
cause she was the only one before me.
- [Narrator] That's literally
the reason why you voted for her?
- Yep.
- [Narrator] Cause you voted for you?
- [Chris] Yep.
- He just said that he fit
all of the Scorpio stereotypes
and that's kind of an easy out.
(electronic music)
- [Narrator] We have a tie.
The tie is between Erica and Chris.
- I was very surprised.
- I was like, oh, okay.
So nobody trusts me.
Like...
- [Narrator] That means we're going into
a second round of votes.
(intense electronic music)
(alarm bell buzzing)
- [Chris] This is BS.
I don't know, like what about me
gave it away to them that like,
if I wasn't a Scorpio
or I sounded like the mole,
but I feel like I was
being very true to myself.
- [Narrator] If everyone feels confident
that you already caught the mole,
you end the game now.
But if the majority has doubt,
the game will continue.
Please raise your hand
if you wanna continue playing the game.
Starting now,
for every time all of you vote out someone
that is not the mole
the total prize money will be reduced.
- [Raina] So for me, I was,
when I was working at a restaurant
one of my coworkers was like,
what's your sign?
And I was like, I'm a Scorpio
and they looked at me
and they were like "I can
tell you have Scorpio eyes."
And I have no idea what that means.
- Scorpio's have like a
very like precise stare.
So when you like,
look at somebody,
it's like you're staring
through their soul.
- Yeah, that happens to me a lot.
Like I actually work with my sister
and we were working a shift together
and she's just like, you know,
I pass by you
and you look mean.
- I feel like people know
that I'm a water sign
but I feel like,
they just mistake it for like cancer.
Actually only Cancer or like Taurus
or something...
- But Taurus, isn't a water sign though.
That's a, that's an earth sign.
My dude, so...
- Yeah, my coworker,
they were like,
a Scorpio is just a Cancer
in a leather jacket.
And I laughed at that
statement until this day.
- Do you guys think your like
style reflects your sign at all
or not really?
- I don't know.
- [Erica] Oh, no.
Cause Scorpios are supposed
to be like really...
- [Giselle] Dark and
mysterious or something, but...
- Yeah. And I'm just like,
I'm like Erykah Badu over here.
(group chuckles)
- Have you guys ever had
like a wild party moment?
- [Michael] There was
this Halloween party.
I guess, I got really drunk
and I was trying to cool down.
It was someone else's house.
So I went in the,
the front where no one was there
and I just passed out.
- No I'm, I don't, I don't party.
(alarm bell dings)
- [Ileana] Oh, maybe he's a Cancer
or a Taurus instead of Scorpio
just acting like he's
Scorpio or something.
- [Giselle] His stories
just kind of did not add up,
in my opinion.
(intense music)
(alarm bell buzzes)
- [Narrator] If everyone feels confident
that you already caught the mole
you can end the game now.
But if the majority has doubt,
the game will continue.
Okay,
majority does not want to continue,
so we will end the game now.
If the light turns green
that means you have voted out the mole
and you win.
If the lights turn red
that means the mole is still in the box
and you lose.
(drum roll)
- I knew it.
I told you so.
I said that we should keep going.
I was right and you were wrong.
- Betrayed by my own self.
- [Narrator] Will the fake
Scorpio please step forward
and reveal yourself in three...
two...
one.
- [Raina] I knew it.
(group sighs)
I knew it.
- I am the only worst
sign that there is Gemini.
When she started mentioning
that I got scared
but my sister's actually the Scorpio.
So we're just channeling
her personality currently.
(group chuckles)
I'm so nervous.
I feel like it's the most
Gemini thing I've ever done.
I really don't wanna
bring hate to the sign
but like didn't know that I would coast
as far as I did,
sweating the whole time.
- My intuition like told me it was her
since the round one,
I was just like,
I just questioned myself
a lot on that one.
- [Giselle] You two,
you mentioned where's your tat,
this is fake.
My friend drew it on me
for this other wrist.
- Yeah. I was looking at it
and I was like,
it looks like a stencil with the Sharpie.
- It's honestly just like eyeliner.
- That's such Gemini behavior.
- It is Gemini behavior, yeah...
- [Raina] Two faced...
(group laughing)
- [Narrator] We wanna thank
all of you for participating.
So we're gonna give you all a gift.
These are bags for you guys.
- [Ileana] Thank you.
What does yours say?
- It just says mole.
(corporate music)
(money whooshing)
- Thank you Natalia,
cause I'm channeling
your energy right now.